[Music]
this week we got Brinks blowout taking
the high road an outdated analog Oh
Brinks like the security trucks are
murder listen Lee Brinks on oh oh so
somebody robbed a Brinks truck I've
always thought that that's the coolest
[ __ ] yeah yeah cuz all supposed to come
out with guns drawn or everything they
do it's so scary there's not that many
of them like John what could take all
those walls yeah easily
I saw the job on the Pennysaver remember
the painting saver yeah the og
Craigslist yeah I wanted a job that was
a minimum wage and under like via armed
guard and then you get paid like 12
bucks an hour and I was like oh [ __ ] I
get twelve dollars and a gun I used to
do that's a dream come true
[ __ ] me I want to get I want to get
robbed like why did he hit it was ours
sucked they were like the hours suck
like they put him on like really weird
shifts and stuff like that and it's
really inflexible at least for him don't
you just sit in a room and play Nintendo
switch the whole time cuz it's not like
it's not just for banks and stuff like
that if they need like a secure
transport somewhere so they had like
we're like for a drive [ __ ] I got a trap
sports on [ __ ] rubies yeah sound like
that yeah but he was talking like crazy
rules like you know like one guy like
sits in the car with nearly I delivers
and then like if that guy gets shot or
whatever he just goes in the car like
drive away with it what yeah like you
can that's incredible
don't you can't see him cuz you're
supposed to protect whatever your yeah
car armed truck is or because he knows
so much if you get shot but he's wounded
you got to pull up to the side and just
[ __ ] formal yeah because he has
information yeah nobody is that was this
top secret and I normally to pay 12 our
bucket I always wanted to see how those
holes work like cuz you know they got a
shotgun in there and they can [ __ ]
put it through the holes there's like
holes on the side of the thing that's so
funny you want to get higher like bokya
and then they show you the holes you're
like I'm out I don't want this job
earning power work there for a week
that's it they're gonna think that
you're gonna try to rob them and show
you learned all the inside secrets ma'am
they're on you maybe I was somewhere in
LA and I went into a KFC I think it was
like when I first moved to LA and the
whole thing was bulletproof like the
whole like you know there's like the
window where you go order yeah looks
like a bank teller right and I was like
I'm not hungry restaurant just puts you
in a whole different that you're just
like I'm so chill yeah he does not eat
my friend her family owned a like a
fried chicken shop in the middle of the
ghetto with that bulletproof glass it
she says like they there's so much that
they try to like rob all the time like
there's a like a bread guy that delivers
like dinner rolls and [ __ ] and he got
robbed
delivery delivering bread they took his
bread Wow they beat him up took the
bread in his hands and then took his
wallet and ran yeah at least they took
the bread wasn't wasted it's the ghetto
yes that bread is pretty good too did
the Brent hit the ground and they still
took the bread it was probably in a bag
okay five-second rules bro
all right so our first story in Indiana
there was a Brinks truck that was on the
highway and we don't know how exactly
but the door swung right open on the
highway and all this cash is just
flowing everywhere and there were bags
of money why do I only read about this
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] dream come true I
would [ __ ] know and the lucky guy in a
[ __ ] Mustang convertible right behind
it is just collecting all of that that's
true convertible shirt okay there were
people pulling over like running into
the interstate man again they might die
today you want a people thing well for
being an idiot yeah well yeah so
initially the troops said the the truth
the state troops they troopers so they
initially said that it was about six
hundred thousand dollars that they later
said that the exact amount is not known
I'm gonna show you guys a clip clip that
is so sad the state police described
people stopping on i-70 walking across
the interstate even jumping over this
fence how do they even know then police
say is not only illegal but very
dangerous yeah but there's
got it money who love a game show oh
[ __ ] drive to work turned into one of
those 20s can decide of Indianapolis in
diamonds show that chaotic scene that is
crazy
when this Brinks truck made an
unexpected deposit right in the middle
of the interstate clever bro
he was pleased with our state state
police say taking this loose money
amounts to theft so they really several
people there to return cash they had
stock you go back on the floor hoping to
catch up with four guys in a white
pickup truck who reportedly made off
with a whole bag of money the other
vehicle that we had a confirmed report
of was a like a school bus for the
driver stop loose bills got back in his
vehicle now be dumped if the whole kid
this is what the pinata training was all
board yeah it's crazy
I love how cops gonna talk like that
yeah he we did have some confirmed
additional reports it's like you could
just said we saw some people [ __ ] you
know stealing cash out of a pic but they
always gotta like you know dance it up
they gotta speak like they're writing a
police report I love it and he and he's
talking to you like there's a gun to his
head he's talking like he doesn't think
it's tight which he thinks it's tight
you could see behind his eyes he thinks
it's something a lot of these cops like
just kind of nervous just to be like it
like like making a statement to like you
know how do people like aren't good in
front of cameras usually it's just like
he's like Brian always brings in that
logic yeah he's like this is my moment
you know what yeah that's true that's
that's my rule well they're supposed to
have camera cops right like I mean what
are you a president it's like just the
cop that just does [ __ ] press stuff
that's all he does maybe I was the first
time he was doing it if it's a small
town they don't got that guy but LAPD
all those like they all have those guys
man would you guys the pullover yes I
could be a [ __ ] billionaire and I was
a drip and stop the whole highway and
then I'll get out
pop her there cops are there and there
we have that's with the cops there
that's my question cuz the guys in the
pickup truck did it right yeah and they
can't catch me
I'll run faster than them I'll just be
running all over [ __ ] putting [ __ ] in
my pocket
and real question now grace dude no
question is when is it enough cuz if
there's that much cash no you have to
make a decision but as you pick it up
you're like oh but I if I just for 30
more seconds and the people got too
greedy they had to turn in their cash
the cops the smart people drove away in
a pickup what about the guards they
didn't come out with guns like everyone
freeze drop the [ __ ] cat right or
they're just sitting inside nobody can't
shoot people that's doing this yeah they
actually said that the Brinks driver
didn't realize that the door was open
until a fellow like a driver in the
highway they were waving him no the
[ __ ] hall monitor drivers what if that
was your money though aren't you happy
that person exists your money's insured
Geo haven't have a heart geo people see
a Brinks truck open up probably grads
day of a whole lives we'll never have
any more significant moment than that
and you of course want to [ __ ] on that
that's too bad too bad that's too bad
nobody can have any fun with you around
Geo's evolving she doesn't want people
to come up I'm just taking care of your
money by okay next stories do you guys
remember those two black guys I got
arrested in Mesilla Philly Starbucks who
brought guys yeah we're doing anything
right yeah they weren't doing anything
we were waiting for an estate investment
meeting yeah they didn't buy anything
didn't leave and then that's when they
got arrested so their names are rashon
Nelson and Dante Robinson
they're both 23 years old and they have
now reached a symbolic one dollar
settlement with the city in exchange for
the creation of a $200,000 program aimed
at young entrepreneurs yeah I read about
this it's pretty so I really really like
the way that they dealt with it pretty
classy and then it's it they didn't
really benefit from it but being able to
give back else why didn't they sue like
crazy and make noise my wife well let me
tell you the rest I would have arranged
a financial statement or a settlement
with Starbucks ha not being said okay
now but that's against the city though
yeah he was a dog with Starbucks they
did reach I would have milked out
everybody but that's just me yeah so
Starbucks also offered to pay for them
to complete their degrees through a
partnership that they have with Arizona
State University wait wait they don't
have their degrees would like to finish
I guess they're working on it right now
so what they're 23 what's going on the
years of turning some things about to be
said I thought that are you Asian during
them I thought I thought they were just
um just like full-on like real estate
developers not going to school I thought
that was a full-time job well and then
now they're gonna go help pay for their
college well maybe they wanted to
further their education and now start
with some kind of paper maybe it's like
their masters and they only have would
be a further their Basinger oh okay all
I'm saying is they could have got so
much more [ __ ] money than a degree or
even know what you mean it's settled
under settled undisclosed yeah well with
the city they got a dollar if I were
them okay I'll be like this [ __ ]
I got 20 mil and guess what instead of
the city I got I got a million dollars
from the city but I'm gonna use this
money to develop my own foundation for
my put my [ __ ] name on it not the
city [ __ ] that I did that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what they gotta do
what's his name
rashon and Dante we're Shawn and Dante
foundation for entrepreneurs that's a
good name actually a little bit smarter
cuz they don't have to do any other work
exactly no no no no but the name though
we could have they could have settled on
it they say what the name is good they
see that's a big thing though they might
have it I would have done that [ __ ] they
could have their name on it I don't got
it I don't with all that money they
could hire a team and do all that [ __ ]
picture speaks a thousand words dude
look at this magnitude they got a lot of
money multitude they got a lot of money
on the settlement for sure he already
got a Apple watch look at that bright
branch shiny new Apple watch that's it
there they did there 23 years old with
the Apple watch yeah they don't mean
that they don't need a name a foundation
therefore they're chill that's pretty
cool though no I I can't I can't knock
that because I think most of us would
have took the greedy route and said
[ __ ] I'm gonna get as much
[ __ ] money as possible and swim in it
and laugh in the faces of the police
yeah tails right but these guys they did
it they did it so classy I don't think I
could be that class this is one of our
Sean said quote when you know that you
did nothing wrong
how do you really react to it you can
either be ignorant or you can show some
type of sophistication and act like you
have class that was a choice me I'll be
so ignorant I think I would get like a
bathtub and poor [ __ ] money in front
of the police station and beats in a
g-string every day as the cops come in
and out of work hey I don't have work
today you are working people would come
up and just take all the cash out of
your bathtub you [ __ ] genius no you
have exposed cash in the public eye and
people will riot 15 seconds ago I have
friends just like forming a circle
around you the wind blows lightly and
just cash is going to the pier and
you're like I figure so I'll figure
something else out alright so yeah yeah
you just ruined this [ __ ] dream hey
man I need or you could rub all the cash
with like poison ivy and people want to
run after and catch it they're like
nouns right
to get poison ivy while I get $17,000
there's communion brick give me a break
who wouldn't do that
put me poor aids all over it I'll give
you guys together make really bad to
suffice by AIDS in a bottle of AIDS
because I'm the one in the g string with
the money I forgot about the D string
brothers you're not gonna join them
let's just stop let's stop what we're
ahead the two of you together would just
end up poor with AIDS that's when you
just stupidest [ __ ] I ever heard Dana D
Street yeah it somehow fun story alright
yo you're living on the streets don't
like how do you how do you fight
discrimination by rubbing it in their
face that's how you win but then we get
AIDS and like die that's that well me
not everyone yeah that's true oh yeah we
have so much money we could be like
magic mr. Johnson's oh yeah AIDS is a
pussy-ass disease I gotta find something
stronger yeah like porn all over like he
caught now equalized
I don't know moving on to the next story
so analog is going out of style
wow that's great you're like a vh1 host
schools in the UK are now getting rid of
analog clocks because students can't
tell time oh let's do god they're so
dumb either [ __ ] just teaching this
is an added stress for students are you
triggered by the [ __ ] clock get a
[ __ ] watch that's what I did why yeah
but okay
in their defense never remember remember
when remember we all remember no but
like when the sundial got phased out for
the clock right yeah remember this no
but I'm sure people when we're pissed or
like sweet all these kids these days
can't read a [ __ ] sundial by everyone
should know how to read a sundial
sundial it's like antiquated right like
so is the [ __ ] living of this [ __ ]
like who needs this it's stupid it's
been stupid since digital came out so
thank god they're phasing out it's a
waste of time that's okay it does beat a
time way faster yeah you get you the
time weight quicker you don't have to
map it out what way
just look at how can easy thank for you
jail we don't have a super brain like
yugioh big fast Jesus know for sure but
but yeah I mean I agree with you now
that everything's digital like why not
so why don't just knock down Big Ben
then yeah that's like one of the biggest
monuments that we should update is
digital yeah change pull the [ __ ]
analog on put a big a digital timer on
the funny thing is and should say the
day of the day yeah and should say it's
Wednesday WD if it's Wednesday their
argument is more stress so it's like
let's let them learn less because it's
more stressful as [ __ ] everything they
try to keep thinking more stress looking
at a clock like you like less like I'm
stressed about the time but I'm not
stressed about reading the time no so
for them it's the fact that they can't
read it and they're stressed out because
they don't know how much time they have
left on their exam like they can't even
read time oh the life skills just some
things you should [ __ ] learn how to
do no look when Steve Jobs wore the same
clothes every single day why cuz he
didn't want to have to think about what
he's gonna wear okay these kids they're
the garden think of all kind of [ __ ]
they don't need to also try to figure
out the time but I bet Steve Jobs gonna
create a clock I bet you Steve Jobs had
digital clocks an Apple can cuz you
thought I was probably a waste of time
don't they not teach cursive anymore
yeah yeah well what about this that make
you just way easier just just an
hourglass when the sand is ran out The
Times up for the test yeah yeah we just
bring back cuckoo clocks I mean is that
it's not extremely analyzer I don't
think it's go coo coo coo but they want
to know how much time is left so they
want to see that bird getting coiled
that big cuckoo is every hour right yeah
well then we'll do it every five minutes
I like it when it goes to delay the
train comes out and then the person
starts dancing I love that it was bad as
Nokia
cuckoo clocks were basically a parody of
jerks bells too because it was always
like ding dong at the hour right yeah
but so cuckoo clocks was like a bit it
was like make it fun I'm like church
bells which I can do that so you know
how like when we wind up our watches
right we always had to like you know see
what time it is like what did they do in
the past like right now I use my phone
or computer to like
dial it up to like oh it's it's the
right time yeah what did I remember back
in the day well at least when I was a
kid we would have a phone number that we
would call in and tell you at the tone
it will be exactly whatever the time was
at with the seconds and so whenever I
was setting up the time around my house
I would always call that I just asked my
mom when the Egyptians were building the
pyramids when is daylight savings time
they had to roll back to sundial take
that [ __ ] like adjusted I think we're
the only country that does that daylight
savings yeah yeah cuz it's farming right
like I would love to see your
information I would love to see the
information we don't do it and they
don't do it in Hawaii and it there's
like some states that don't do it like
Arizona or something I wish we got on
that well no no I love daylight saving
sounds like the best time in the whole
year it's like surprise we have more
hours or it's like life's a little more
interesting now something's a little
different that's that a little bit of
zest in it the monotony is not the same
yeah it's like when we get a cloudy day
in California yeah Wow
back to my shitty life but it's a little
different opening up the doors just like
okay yeah in this article they're
mentioning that there was a senior
pediatric doctor that said earlier this
year a lot of young children are finding
it increasingly difficult to just use a
pencil like they're not using so like
we're gonna [ __ ] ban the pencil so no
right now I know right a lot of kids
they're just being shoved just iPads and
digital things I don't they're not
really working with their hands like
building blocks or play-doh or like
coloring they're not doing you know
they're not asking they're actually
because they're using more advanced [ __ ]
they're coloring on with every single
color that's available in the human that
the human eye can see but you can't even
hold a pencil now like did why should
answer it's antiquated Tecna I think I
think that in the future we won't even
like you're gonna use tablets and [ __ ]
that's why they say grey aliens are
actually evolved humans that are coming
back in time because they [ __ ] lost
the way thank you
exactly alien no let's see the what I'm
saying is like the big big guy alien
that's like you don't know if they're
male or female and then they're just
bald and all over gray there was a time
where we used to dip a quill
in dink and then we would write right
and that's like a dip again hope guys
pain yes and then the pen came out and
it's like you know all these kids don't
even know how to use a quill pen anymore
like that's how this [ __ ] is to me you
guys have this thing from [ __ ]
pressing so hard on your pencil mm-hmm
challenges I don't know if that's even a
callus what's gonna happen when like
something should happens in the world
and we can't use the technology that we
have now where you become so [ __ ]
anyway they just figure out something
else
I do like knowing like maybe not two
steps not maybe not the quill or
whatever like cave paintings but I think
I do like knowing one step before before
you use technology so you kind of
understand the philosophy of how it
works so for example like if you know
how to use like a DSLR camera and then
if you have autofocus on your phone
whatever I think you'll be a better
photographer for just knowing the backup
like that one last step before the super
easy type it's waste of brain space I
think how are you sure yeah if you're
gonna not gonna use it yeah
I'd rather learn more no less yeah yeah
that's a good point
[Music]